[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que nos
lleva a conocer los alcances de una de
las mafias más famosas de la historia la
cosa nostra unitaria hacia sicilia a
mediados del siglo 19 y rápidamente se
convirtió en una de las ramas más
poderosas de la mafia italiana es
también conocida como el pulpo por su
capacidad para infiltrarse en todos los
ámbitos de la sociedad y tener brazos en
otros territorios en el siglo 20 se
instaló en nueva york y en chicago el
famoso el padrino en la película en el
francés por coppola era miembro de la
cosa nuestra
hace 30 años la justicia italiana lanzó
una contraofensiva con el ministerio
fiscal de palermo en primera línea uno
de esos magistrados se convirtió en un
símbolo en la lucha contra la mafia
el juez giovanni falcone la cosa nuestra
ordenó su asesinato el 23 de mayo de
1992 600 kilos de explosivos estallaron
al paso de su vehículo también murieron
su esposa y tres guardaespaldas menos de
dos meses después el también juez paolo
borsellino murió en un carro bomba esta
serie de asesinatos desató una toma de
conciencia y la cosa nuestra
aparte del poder que tenía en la isla
todavía cuenta con miles de miembros
pero cada vez más sicilianos se rehúsan
a pagar el piso el impuesto que la amav
impone a los comerciantes aún en la
actualidad la lucha contra los mafiosos
continua
[Música]
un montón de chatarra
eso es todo lo que queda del vehículo
que escoltaba al juez antimafia giovanni
falcone
frenado en seco este auto pasó a la
historia italiana
[Música]
todavía siento mucha rabia y me gustaría
en fin pienso que no hice lo suficiente
para evitar que esto sucediera
me acuerdo de ese día estaba muy joven
sólo se veía eso en la televisión
ya he sido escolta de algunas
celebridades así que eso me impresiona
todavía más
este año lo que queda del auto viaja por
italia en este pueblo de a bruce como
cada lugar en el que pasa despiertan las
mismas emociones y le habla a los más
jóvenes sobre la violencia de cosa
nostra
[Música]
quien tiene los valientes
este mortal y camino
en el auto y bueno guardaespaldas vito
esquí funk y rock o de chilo y antonio
montinaro
están ahí
tiene conserva algunas fotos de su
esposo el guardaespaldas de giovanni
falcone
antonio está justo ahí
siempre con el juez balcón halcón como
cuando lo conocí cuando lo conocí no
solo me enamoré de un hombre atractivo
también me enamoré a sus decisiones de
lo que lo motiva adentro
con tan sólo 24 años antonio se ofreció
como voluntario para escoltar al
personaje más expuesto de italia el 23
de mayo de 1992 el policía no estaba de
servicio pero intercambio su turno con
un colega
sonó el teléfono me llamó una amiga y me
dijo escucha hubo un atentado contra el
west balcón y falcón
y después de eso me fui a la comisaría y
las escenas se encadenaron una detrás de
otra
me volví parte de una historia que no
había escogido
la visitó
o incluso aunque él me lo había
advertido me dijo que un día tendría que
recoger sus restos y que no quedaría
nada de él
desde entonces tina se ha quedado en
sicilia
para continuar la lucha de su marido
contra la mafia
hoy se reúne con unos niños
desfavorecidos de palermo
hola
como están
en esta iglesia
los educadores acogen a los jóvenes
después de la escuela
solo me quedé aquí porque creo en el
pienso que ustedes son mejores que
nosotros y que sean curiosos que hagan
preguntas
nunca más deben darle su consentimiento
a la magia a la materia
algunos de estos alumnos tienen
familiares en la cárcel finales de apoyo
con su trato cariñoso
y tú que va a ser de ti qué quieres
hacer cuando seas grande la grande
la sesión está seguro bote
[Música]
un portero
porque juegas fútbol
para los jóvenes sicilianos las figuras
de los jueces paolo borsellino y
giovanni falcone se volvieron
legendarias este dibujo está inspirado
en una famosa fotografía
lo que yo pensé que sólo era una buena
fotografía de dos personas se convirtió
en otra cosa ya no es una foto sino un
símbolo un signo de unidad
en marzo de 1992 el fotorreportero tony
gentile asistió a una conferencia de
prensa donde estaban los dos magistrados
[Música]
este la secuencia ésta es la secuencia
de las 4 o 5 fotos que tomé ese día en
ese momento me acerque a ellos ellos
también se acercaron y recibió se
estaban riendo entonces empecé a tomar
las fotos
el fotograma y es en esta la número 15
donde salen más auténticos
una imagen excepcional de los dos amigos
sonriendo no les quedaban más que
algunas semanas de vida giovanni falcone
y paolo borsellino eran conscientes del
peligro que corrían encuesta foto
esta foto realmente hace resonar las
palabras de paolo borsellino cuando
decía no
soy un muerto que camina el software de
la suba se ve en su mirada es la
expresión de su carne de la atención del
bolton
los dos jueces fueron asesinados con 57
días de diferencia la imagen de su
complicidad se convirtió en el emblema
de toda una generación
[Música]
este tramo de la autopista fue el que
estalló cuando pasó el auto del juez
falcone matando a cinco personas
a mi alrededor veía a los policías
confundidos no sabían qué hacer
mario risso bono tenía entonces 13 años
y el evento lo marcó profundamente ahora
dirige una agencia que organiza viajes
centrados en la resistencia de la mafia
a su derecha está el túnel donde
metieron 500 kilos de explosivos y un
número puso ahí se arrastró al interior
con dificultad
acostado sobre una patineta y salió
jalado por una cuerda
hoy pero está haciendo un tour para unos
alumnos que vienen del norte de italia
pues igual la colina desde la que se
puede ver el lugar del atentado
todo estaba perfectamente calculado
tuvieron que cuidar cada detalle incluso
pusieron una nevera vieja a un lado de
la autopista esa era la señal cuando los
autos pasaron por delante era el momento
de detonar la bomba la mayoría de estos
jóvenes italianos nunca había estado en
cecilia la descubren por primera vez a
través de este relato
soltando
escuchar los testimonios de las personas
permita entender mejor y sentir las
emociones de los que lo vivieron
es muy conmovedor venir a estos lugares
vuelve a dar confianza refuerza la
voluntad de luchar contra esto en
nuestras vidas y en nuestra sociedad
los detonadores de la bomba se
escondieron justo aquí donde está
pintada la inscripción no mafia
como un mantra
margherita
romana con que usted la
a esta pizzería hace parte de nuestro
tour
este restaurante no paga el pizza desde
hace mucho tiempo
por eso es uno de los lugares
importantes de nuestra visita y bueno
también tengo que decirlo porque la
pizza es deliciosa
el piso es el impuesto de extorsión que
la mafia impone a los comerciantes
mariana ya no lo paga no te va a burlar
antes no podía ni hablar de eso era la
ley del silencio nadie decía nada hoy
nos sentimos más libres y podemos dar
nuestra opinión decir lo que pensamos
todo ha cambiado es una realidad
diferente hay libertad unos mil
comerciantes hacen parte de esta red de
anti piso pero se estima que un 70 por
ciento de los comercios de la isla
todavía paga este impuesto
nos reunimos con uno de los asesinos de
esta organización criminal
[Música]
esté arrepentido miembro de la cosa
nuestra aprendió a pintar en la cárcel
[Música]
me gusta el rojo resalta la luz no puedo
recibirlos en mi casa porque eso me
podría causar algunos problemas pm en la
cárcel gaspar moto lo se encontró con
totó rina el jefe de la cosa nostra
que ordenó el asesinato de los jueces
[Música]
me dijo lo siento pero es más fácil
matar que robar porque disparar bam bam
toma dos minutos no debes tener miedo de
hacerlo yo era un simple ladrón y él me
dijo que yo debía tener menos miedo de
matar que de robar porque tomaba menos
tiempo
gaspar motor se unió entonces a cosa
nostra delante de la justicia reconoció
haber cometido más de 20 homicidios
conocía muy bien el juez giovanni
falcone
él fue quien convenció a gaspar de
arrepentirse y confesar
el asesinato de falcone ya estaba
decidido y se tuvo que adelantar porque
lograba hacer hablar a demasiados
mafiosos
era un problema para la mafia de
víctimas
por iniciativa del juez falcone en 1991
se empezó a ofrecer protección y
reducción de la sentencia de los
mafiosos que colaboraban con la justicia
en el palacio de justicia de palermo una
nueva generación de magistrados continúa
con el trabajo
ya sabe es la fiscal general de palermo
puesto en esta puerta lleva a las
oficinas donde trabajaban falcone y
borsellino falcón and war seller
la magistrada empezó su carrera como
jueza en un tribunal ordinario en roma'
el asesinato de los dos jueces cambió su
rumbo decidió ir a cecilia para
investigar sobre la cosa no sólo
debajo de esta foto está escrito sus
ideas seguirán avanzando a través de
nosotros
entonces cada vez que veo su foto me
acuerdo de la razón por la que vine aquí
él ya sabe vive bajo protección desde
hace 24 años le debe parte de su
metodología de trabajo a los jueces
falcone y borsellino en particular la
manera de rastrear los flujos
financieros de las redes de la másica
hoy en día la mafia tiene un perfil bajo
ya no hay baños de sangre pero cosas
nuestra sigue activa
con el cob y sabemos que le dio dinero
en efectivo a las empresas que tenían
dificultades con el objetivo de
apropiarse de esas actividades
comerciales
aunque sus métodos hayan evolucionado la
mafia todavía tiene una presencia fuerte
en sicilia una investigación reciente
acaba de concluir con el arresto de 31
personas sospechosas de estar vinculadas
con la mafia en palermo en la plaza de
la catedral y ya sabe está presente en
el acto conmemorativo por la
desaparición de los jueces me acuerdo de
ese momento hace 30 años
me acuerdo del dolor desgarrador me
acuerdo de la desesperanza desde
entonces hemos hecho nuestro mejor
esfuerzo es necesario seguir hay que
continuar por los niños y por los nietos
de quienes murieron hace 30 años
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y la mayor parte de la audiencia son
jóvenes que nacieron después de 1992 no
vivieron los atentados que sacudieron a
cecilia
los alumnos de dos escuelas de policía
desfilan por las calles hasta llegar al
puerto a su lado la viuda del policía
antonio montinaro
y
les agradezco y espero que sigan
adelante con valentina
que vean a sus jóvenes colegas como
ejemplos como un faro
esta nueva generación parece determinada
a luchar contra la mafia
me volví policía precisamente para esto
para que mi ciudad palermo cambie para
hacer que las cosas cambien incluso
aunque sé que será difícil
y quiero continuar con el trabajo de
falcone y de borsellino y de ser posible
acabarlo cumplir con su compromiso con
sus ideas
[Música]
un deseo honorable ampliamente
compartido en cecilia frente a una
batalla aún lejos de poderse ganar
[Música]
llegamos al final de ese episodio de
boleto de vuelta a la cosa nuestra
recuerde que si quiere ver este y otros
episodios en español puede visitar
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
hasta pronto